Please welcome a very good old friend, Sarah Gilbert.
( audience cheering )
Hi
Oh my gosh! You look gorgeous.
Oh thank you, you too.
I mean, we just celebrated this lovely, beautiful girl
Carly who's 17 and behaving in a way that I
hope my children grow up to be like, I.
I know, it's unbelievable to be a teenager
and have that much of yourself be that creative.
And I think it's just such a great lesson to people.
What you can accomplish in any direction, you know
that you can have an idea
and actually put it out in the world is pretty incredible.
So now the longevity
of Roseanne now there's a family we all grew up with,
and now with the Connors,
I mean how do you explain the longevity and the success
of the Connors being such an apart of the American fabric?
If you will, I've never said that sentence
but it comes to mind when I think
about what you guys have done with the show.
Oh, thank you.
I mean, I think, you know
a lot of it is attributable to luck.
It's just the right group of people and the right chemistry
and another part of it is
the writing staff is just incredible.
They're really phenomenal.
And then another piece I suppose, is just
that there aren't a lot of stories on television
about working class families and trying to break the cycle
of poverty, trying to get ahead.
And so I think we're trying to get
into the nitty gritty of what
what is it like to try to be surviving and getting ahead
in this country and not quite being able to do it?
I have to agree.
The show is not tone deaf and also we all need comedy.
And one of the reasons I was so like
enamored of you, working alongside of you
and watching you like everyone else is,
damn girl, you are so funny and you can be dry.
And that's such a hard art to pull off.
I don't think I could pull off dry.
I'm like goof.
I'm like Marty Feldman.
I'm like, I'm funny in your face.
And you're just like cocky, confident, dry, like,
God how do you do that?
But that's a good balance you need that need both.
Well we make..
And you're the all heart, you know
ooey gooey heart sweetness, that people need.
Well, I love being a pair with you.
(upbeat music)